Hi, I'm Ramona J. Smith , Toastmasters
International 2018 World Champion of
Public Speaking. Have you ever
been asked to give a toast,
but you didn't know what to say? I know
first-hand that speaking in front of an
audience is one of the most demanding situations
you can face. Yet I'm one of millions of people
who Toastmasters has helped gain the confidence
to communicate in all circumstances.
When friends gather to celebrate, some occasions
are more formal than others, but even a formal
occasion doesn't have to be intimidating. The
first tip will help you succeed with any toast.
One: Keep it short and sweet
One skill that Toastmasters learn is how to
get to the point. With a toast, this is especially
important. You want to stand up, raise your glass,
and say a few words to make everyone smile, but
do it in a way that is brief and engaging.
Since you're keeping it to a few
minutes, what should you talk about?
That might depend on the situation.
Toasts happen at all types of events, not
just weddings. For example, many memorial services
reserve time for guests to honor the departed.
For a eulogy, it's a good idea to focus on
celebrating the positive and most important
parts of that person's life. Highlight a few
remarkable things that they accomplished,
but make it a short list. Platitudes,
cliches, or long chronologies may not
only bore some listeners; they will
steal the impact of your message.
Instead, try to express what gave that
person joy and a sense of accomplishment.
For a wedding, speak from the
heart, and wish the couple well.
You might mention one aspect of their relationship
that you admire, but be sure it's appropriate.
Two: Be Careful with humor
Humor has a place in every toast, regardless of
the setting, just remember to be empathetic to
the honoree and the circumstances. For a wedding
toast, avoid potentially embarrassing stories.
Risqu jokes or anecdotes as a part of a
toast for any celebration can be hazardous.
You're better off if you keep the focus
on the person or the event being honored,
and not on stories the couple, their guests,
or other honoree might find uncomfortable.
Three: Practice
When your goal is a great toast, practice
at least once or twice before the big event.
Rehearse the words you'd like to
say, but also plan an opening.
To begin, stand up, raise your glass,
and say, I'd like to propose a toast.
Then, practice giving your fellow celebrants
time to raise their glasses before you speak.
Also, you may not have access to a microphone, so
if you'll be addressing a large gathering, it's
a good idea to practice projecting your voice.
Don't yell, but breathe deeply, and let your voice
radiate from your center. Practice will help.
With a little preparation and practice, you can
master the art of toasting and help make every
celebration an event to remember. Cheers!